what's going on guys this is rob and one
of the things that i love about the rob
core is how you guys work together
you know i know for for a while aaron
wilder was asking about
uh asking for like beyond omega level
stuff and
it was kind of it was kind of funny
because initially it was just him
and then you guys started like jumping
on the bandwagon right and it like and
then you guys were getting you guys were
grouping up into packs
like groups of you guys were like
getting together and like
like aaron wilder would ask and then it
would get like 300 likes and everybody
would comment and be like don't worry
aaron we're going to make sure you get
this right
it was it's cool to see i'd love to see
the rob core working together in that
way you guys are awesome in that way so
in the spirit of that i need your all's
help um
there's a fan that i have named john
and i haven't talked to john for quite
some time but john lived in london
colorado and when i first moved out
there
john was one of the people that i talked
to right i just kind of said hey does
anybody here love them want to hang out
and john and i got lunch
and john was working out right he has
like a gym and all that kind of stuff
and i'm moving back to loveland
in like between april and may so
sometime in the in early to mid april
and i wanted to hit up john so we could
start working out because i'm trying to
you know live a healthier lifestyle
so john if you're still a fan and you
happen to see this
um that'd be awesome if you if you just
send me an email right
if any of you guys out there know the
guy that i'm talking about like he's
like a friend of yours or something like
that
just nudge him and say hey man like rob
is trying to get a hold of you uh just
send him an email real quick and just
just see what's up
uh because it'd be cool it'd be really
really awesome for us to work out
together because john was a cool guy he
was a pacific islander i think
so he was he was enormous right and not
like overweight the guy was just
had just like a big body structure right
like he was muscular as hell it was
crazy i was like jesus man
but the guy's gym he had like a comet
based gem right so like he had pictures
like the avengers and stuff
and his plates had like avengers designs
on them and there's like batman and
things like that i was like that's legit
it was awesome but yeah if you guys
could really help me out with that that
would be
awesome that'd be amazing the other
thing i want to thank you guys for the
response to pop culture explain
it's awesome right like i'm actually
looking at the channel right now on
youtube it's awesome we're at almost 8
000 subscribers
um so we've gained about 7 000
subscribers in the last 30 days
the wanda vision video that we did has
like 10 000 views so it got into the
algorithm which is awesome
so that's that's thanks to you guys
right that's thanks to you guys for
for helping us pull that off um you know
it's it's cool like i love what we're
doing over at pop culture explain like i
love the content that we're making out
there it's fun
it's exciting it gives us like you know
infinite opportunity to grow in a wide
array of different directions
if i'm being honest it's one of the
things that there was always the thing
one of the things i didn't necessarily
like about
comics explained is there's a lot of
content that you guys love
that goes beyond the comic books right
godzilla like the movies and stuff like
that
and those are things that i always
wanted to cover but they weren't really
things that i could cover on comics
explained because the comics explained
brand is a comic book channel
but with a pop culture explained brand
it's anything related to pop culture
and so i think this is finally a shot
you know finally a chance for
for me to be able to cover a lot of the
content that you guys have been wanting
to see
this is not just comic book based the
only thing that i probably wouldn't be
able to do because a lot of people have
asked about this
is anime and manga and it's not because
i'm not interested
it's because the anime and manga
companies do not mess around
and they strike the hell out of channels
that post up anime and manga right so
the last thing i want to do is launch a
pop culture explained channel and it
gets shut down three months in because a
copyright strikes
those guys do not play it's it's it's
intense right so
it's not because i don't care or i'm not
interested or i'm just ignoring anybody
who wants anime and manga
it's not like that it's just because of
the fact that anime and manga channels
are
super quick on the trigger when it comes
to issuing copyright strikes and getting
channels shut down so
that's kind of the downside but for
everything else like i know that we're
doing it like they moved up
the release of godzilla versus kong to
like march 26 so we're doing
like we're gonna do a video on godzilla
and then we're gonna do one on kong just
like
godzilla explained kong explained stuff
like that like it's it's
fun it's it's super cool right it's
super cool we're doing like celebrities
explained which is really awesome
that's kind of a niche thing at the
moment like we did stan lee explained
and like we're just explaining
celebrities
uh which is fun it's enjoyable i think
chadwick boseman is coming up soon
um we've got we've got like i think
we're probably gonna do like a youtuber
edition so like explaining youtubers
which i i'm really excited about that
because what i'm looking forward to the
most in that
is kind of giving shout outs to smaller
youtubers that are trying to grow
right because there's like a lot of
comic book youtubers out there that are
trying to grow their brand
and can't really and are having a
difficult time doing it because of the
nature of the algorithm or the new rules
that youtube put in place things like
that
and even like youtubers that i watch
outside of comic books right they're
trying to get their name out there
trying to grow
gaming youtubers different things like
that you know and so on so
um i think i think it'd be cool right to
like explain those youtubers right to
him up say hey give us some bullet
points about the stuff you're interested
in us explaining
and then we'll make a video on you and
then we'll release it and people will
know who you are and you can get some
exposure
i like that i like that idea so um
anyway i think it's important this is
one of the things i think is really
really important as a youtuber
is to give back to the community that
has given me so much right
because my channel wouldn't be coming to
explain wouldn't be where it was if it
wasn't for you guys being as awesome as
you are right i've got fans i've got
i've got fans
it's one of the coolest things about
being comics explained i've got fans
who have been here since i had like a
thousand subscribers
i met one of you guys in denver comic
con it was the coolest thing in the
world right it was
oh all dude was the coolest thing in the
world i met one of you guys at denver
comic con
i recorded a video i put it on instagram
and everything right like i'm i'm at
denver comic con right this is
i love story time i love telling stories
you guys you guys know you guys know how
i get excited
right you guys you guys know how i get
excited right so so i'm at denver comic
con
this this video requesting help to find
a guy named john has just
totally gone off the rails okay so i was
at denver comic-con one year
and um and and i'm just walking around
the con floor right just kind of walking
around and looking at things and
checking stuff out
and like benny or saller somebody sends
me a text and says hey man
uh there's a fan here looking for you
and i was like okay well then give me a
few minutes and i'll be back there right
because we had a table set up
and i told people ahead of time like hey
come check us out at denver comic con
i may not necessarily be at that table
but if i'm not there hit up benny or
somebody they'll get a hold of me and
i'll come over there and i'll hang out
right
and so so i get over there and like it's
a fan right this guy
who's been following me since i had a
thousand subscribers on youtube this guy
flipped like as soon as he saw me he was
like oh my god he started losing his
mind
it was the coolest thing ever right i
had i met a fan of baltimore comic con
again this little bitty figurine
of lex luthor in his battle armor like
his his green and purple battle armor
it was awesome right like it was it's
stuff it's stuff like that
right comics explain is successful a lot
of you know partly because of the work
that i've put in you know cranking out
content things like that
but also because i think that here with
the rob core in our fan base
we've amassed a pretty awesome group of
people and i i love that idea
i love the idea of being able to say
like we've amassed an awesome fan base
right of people from all walks of life
doctors and lawyers and teachers and
and and like like people who work all
these different kinds of professions
right just
all these different kinds of professions
who just have a love of comics
and love to just kind of hang out with
me while i get super excited and talk
about amazing things like when franklin
richards
resurrected galactus from the dead and
made him his herald
like stuff like that right like just
just things like that right it's just
it's it's exciting it's exciting it's
it's super exciting but
um but yeah i think i think that as a
youtuber
one of the most important things to do
is to give back to the community right
it's to give back to the community
and that's why i like the idea of using
pop culture explain as it means to one
uh expose you know to bring exposure to
smaller youtubers who would have a hard
time getting it on their own
and then two just kind of cover topics
that you guys would love to see
that i just wouldn't normally be able to
cover on comics explain so
anyway guys um yeah if you guys can help
me find john that would be awesome uh
i'll be scouring my email hopefully
john's still a fan he may have moved on
or may have
you know started to to you may not
necessarily be a fan of the content that
we're creating right now on comics
explain
which is fine people grow they change
their interests change and that's just
the nature of the world but uh anyway
guys we're gonna bring this to an
end um hopefully you guys can help me
out here and i will catch you all later
peace